So in this problem, we're going to build a bit of a spambot.
Let's take an email address. Let's take my email address.
Let's say I post this on the internet,
but I don't want an automatic robot to go from every page, see my email address,
and then start sending me SPAM.
So I come up with a solution to insert the characters, NOSPAM,
somewhere in my email address.
Presumably, a crawling spambot won't be able to notice that this isn't actually
part of my email address, and I put that in there just as a distraction.
But a human will see my email address, realize that NOSPAM isn't actually
part of my email address--who would really put that there?--
and just email to pchapman@udacity.com.
Well, what we're going to do is build our lexer such that it matches email addresses,
and the value of the token that it returns is going to remove NOSPAM from it.
So what are we going to need?
We're going to need to find our tokens and presumably, we're going to have 1 called email.
Remember our tokens are going to use all capitalization, just as convention.
Then we're going to want to define the function that matches that token.
So now we have to write our regular expression that matches an email address.
So the exact specifications for the email address are given in the problem specification.
But to go over it briefly, we're going to have a sequence of letters with any capitalization,
followed by an @ sign, and then we can have another sequence of letters
followed by at least 1 dot and then more letters,
possibly followed by another dot and more letters,
but it doesn't end on a dot. You need to have some letters.
So that's kind of the verbal walk through.
Let's start writing it out.
So we're going to match the letters before the @ sign.
It's going to be this chunk right here.
Then we're going to match the @ sign--this bit.
So this part of a regular expression is going to match everything up to the last chunk of letters.
This last chunk is called the top level domain--.com, .net, .edu--things like that.
We're going to map with this regular expression everything before that.
The specification for that is some letters followed by a period,
and that whole thing can be repeated as many times as necessary,
and at the end, we have our last bit of letters.
For whatever this matches, we're going to remove the NOSPAM,
and we're going to do that using the RE library,
which you're hopefully pretty familiar with by now.
This method in particular allows us to replace matching substrings with other substrings.
In this case, we're going to replace all of the occurrences of NOSPAM with nothing.
Also don't forget to define the error state where if it doesn't match anything,
we're just going to skip it.
The last thing we need to write is a code that builds the lexer and runs it
on our given haystack--our given text of the webpage or whatnot of the email addresses.
For that I'm going to go to the ID.
Here I have the code I just wrote.
I declare 1 token--that's the email.
The definition matches our regular expression for email addresses
and removes all of the occurrences of NOSPAM.
I have something for when we hit an error, where nothing is matched.
Now I just need to write the code that builds the lexer.
So I'm going to basically follow what we did in lecture.
This builds the lexer. Now we need to assign it the input.
We're going to go through every token it matches and instill a list of results.
I'm going to call that result. Here I go.
For every token that we get, if I'm out of tokens, I'm going to break,
but for all the ones that we do have, I'm going to append it to the result list
and then return the result list.